James how many years of your life did
you work on this film well I it began as
a screenplay
for HBO in the late 1990s so nearly 20
years ago I I'm a New Yorker I grew up
very familiar with the iconic story of
kitty Genovese murder
38 eyewitnesses watched for more than a
half hour while woman was repeatedly
attacked none helped that story that we
all know that helped conspire the night
when one emergency system neighborhood
watch groups Good Samaritan laws that
story was so defining of New York and
America in many respects in any New
Yorker many New Yorkers are very
familiar with it so I am a as a
screenwriter drawn to iconic stories we
think we know and this is an iconic
story I had done a screenplay about the
Lincoln assassination called The
Conspirator that Robert Redford had
directed and before that I did a mini or
limited series called the Bronx is
burning about New York in the late 1970s
with John Turturro and Oliver Platt so
kitty Genovese his murder seemed to me
like a a very interesting compelling
story to do as a screenplay because at
the center of it just an incredible
mystery what happened in those
apartments that night and it was at that
time that I met the subject of the
witness bill Genovese so it started in a
sense 20 years ago he did not become a
documentary film nothing came of that
HBO project but I stayed in touch with
Bill I was very struck when I met bill
the first time firstly you meet him and
you spend all of about two minutes and
you understand how remarkable he is and
what he's overcome in his life age 16
his sister was murdered 17 his mother
had a stroke when she was 53 and 19 bill
lost both legs in Vietnam and at 21 his
father had a stroke at the age of 59 all
in a five-year period
and yet bill has had a remarkable and
full life beautiful family so you're
sort of struck by how remarkable he is
most striking perhaps if you're
interested or have been interested in
the story of kitty Genovese when you
meet bill as you meet Kitty the person
she's only known to all of us for the
last thirty minutes of her life and yet
she was this remarkably independent
woman she drove a red Fiat convertible
managed a barmaid three times most of
three times with the men she knew made
she met her lover in a bar in Greenwich
Village by leaving a note on her door
and telling her to be at a payphone at a
point at a time it's really dynamic
independent woman and you meet that
person through bill and then and this
was perhaps the most haunting didn't
realize it at the time is just how
affected bill was not just by the loss
of his sister but the way she reportedly
died that story of 38 watching and none
helping propelled the course of his life
he was determined he said to prove that
he was not only would have been one of
the people who opened the window that
night but would have gone down into the
street nothing came of that scripted
project but I maintained sort of
connection to bill and then in 2004 the
New York Times questioned its original
story what were there really 38 did they
really see what we reported they had
they had what is that they said that we
said that they saw so bill who was
completely impacted by that story needed
to find out for himself and so beginning
in 2004 11 years ago bill set off on
this now decade-plus investigation to
unravel that and many other mysteries
and so the long that was a long answer
to your question but the short answer is
as a documentary over the past 11 years
bill Genovese kitty Genovese brother
admits to his family and to the camera
that he's obsessed with the store
how much did you become obsessed with
the story either in the beginning or
during the course of finding out new
information you know they're there
they're very different
I guess one can define obsession in
different ways for Bill he is trying to
find answers to unanswerable questions
in a way but there are multiple
mysteries that he's in pursuit of one is
what happened that night what happened
in those apartments and as he discovers
that the story that we've all come to
know isn't true he wants to find out how
that story came to be who told who
created that story that we all know and
that had such an impact and then there's
the mystery of who was his sister she's
only known to him for the life she led
in New Canaan where he lived but she
lived a full life in New York City and
so he wants to find out who was who was
my sister and the last mystery is the
person who killed his sister Winston
Moseley what kind of person would do
that
so Bill's obsession is a self-proclaimed
is about finding answers to questions
that have propelled the whole course of
his life I wouldn't describe mine as an
obsession I was documenting Phil's
journey but the this the the idea is
this the things that come up as a result
of Bill's investigation the power of
these flawed and false narratives are
things that I think any storyteller any
filmmaker screenwriter journalist lives
and contemplates how and any human being
we we all have a photo that sits on a n
table owner or on our desk and we've
crafted a whole story around what
happened and who when who took that
photo of what was going on and that
story may not even be true but it's
shaped our lives
similarly and I think this happened on
the night Katie was murdered
we we all hear things sometimes outside
our window and craft a narrative as to
what's going on outside
so what Bill's investigation on the
unraveling of this fall snare multiple
false narratives does is resonates I
think not just with me but with the
viewer so like Bill like the audience
I'm in a sense on four on the ride with
Bill as he's unraveling I just will say
as a screenwriter I could never have I
don't have the talent to create a an
individual a person as compelling as
courageous remarkable is empathic as
dogged as bill Genovese he is the most
remarkable person and character that I
will ever portray you said he had an
ability to put people at ease just
instantly you know upon meeting them and
do you think that that's part of the
success of getting so many just in-depth
real interviews from the quote unquote
various subjects for a half century so
many have been chewing on this story
journalists academics screen writers
musicians graphic novelists the Opera
four weeks ago girls does an episode
called Hello Kitty based on kitties
Jenna Reese's murder eight weeks ago Law
& Order SVU does an episode based on
kitty Genovese is murder it took place
52 years ago but they're still it's
still inspiring contemporary dramas but
what is interesting what is notable and
that this was where I was going with
that what would is notable is that we
really haven't heard from those who were
the most directly impacted
either by Kitty's life or her death and
it really took bill to get them these
people to share their stories and the
reason I think they wanted to speak to
biller we're willing to speak to bill is
one I think many particularly the
witnesses particularly the eye and ear
witnesses felt they owed it to Kitty and
by Bill being as close to Kitty as
anyone he was their surrogate she's her
surrogate and felt they would share it
with Bill but the other thing and I
think this speaks to what's singular
about Bill he has been a double amputee
since he was 19 and has he has said that
when people meet him initially they're
uncomfortable and he puts them at ease
so much so that you actually forget his
disability and that's how the film sort
of portrays his disability you just
forget you just move on and so this and
the ability to make people comfortable I
think is part of his is a singular skill
in a way and and many in the film are
holding on to narratives to stories that
are deeply painful and they share these
memories with Bill because they realize
that he understands innately emotional
and physical trauma because he's lived
it he gets it and so they're willing to
open up to him you got to keep in mind
that most of the people in the film are
not selfie generation they have they're
not used to being photographed much less
filmed and they were only willing to do
it I in my opinion because of Bill what
we were thoughts to possibly filming a
face to face interview with Winston
Moseley and Bill Genovese so Winston
Moseley is the convicted killer of kitty
Genovese what were your thoughts on that
were you scared
did you see you know Bill's reaction to
it and react off him
I think for over the course of decades
bill has had this push-pull about
meeting his sister's killer on the one
hand as he says in the film he one
wanted to know what his life was like to
get it to size size up the man that
murdered his sister on the other hand
not seeing him would be a great relief
because of the anxiety I think the
natural progression of his investigation
was towards meeting Winston Moseley and
as a filmmaker when you're year after
year with somebody you understand what
their need and their desire the
mechanics of doing it is interesting
there's a program in the state of New
York whereby the they size up they have
to evaluate whether the victim or the
victim's family is capable of handling
the meeting with a perpetrator of the
crime and they then go to the prison
without it being announced to ask once
they've okayed in a sense of prove the
person to go meet with the the convicted
person they then go and ask or try to
get there okay so it's a it's a process
and so what I think was most affecting
and most poignant was Bill's desire the
impact of Bill's desire to meet with his
sister's murder on the rest of his
family and and just how difficult that
was for his honest family
are you certain in your mind that
Winston Moseley is the killer of kitty
Genovese oh there there's no there's no
debt he confessed to the crime multiple
times his defense was a psychiatric it
was an insanity defense so yeah there's
no question that he perpetrated the
crime then the film
never explores his guilt or innocence
now Winston Moseley offers up and did
over the course of multiple decades
narratives as to what took place
shifting narratives but yet though
there's no question and you should know
that Winston Moseley actually passed
away in in late late March of this year
after serving nearly 52 years in jail
and in prison and I would recommend any
of your viewers look up the letter to
the editor that Phil Genovese just
googled William Genovese letter to the
editor times and it's a remarkable
letter and it gives you a sense of just
what kind of person bill is were you
surprised at Winston Moseley son's
reaction I was taken aback at how he
tried to almost throw it back on Kitty
and the family without giving too much
away I was just kind of shocked well
like if the question is does it surprise
me that
Steven Mosley who was seven years old
when his father brutally murdered kitty
Genovese and a few weeks earlier had
brutally murdered another woman would
grow up with a narrative that made his
father seem less culpable and his victim
seemed more to blame no that's not
surprising because after all this is his
father and in order to live with a
reality that your father is essentially
a budding serial killer you would need
or want to hold on to stories that might
make it more palatable I think that's in
many respects what Bill is unraveling
again and again and again the stories
that we tell ourselves then enable us to
get through the night when we hear
something outside the window or across
50 years
how often would you meet with bill
Genovese to film the interviews and go
over the movie there was a small group
of us a cinematographer co-producer
cinematographer named Trish go boney
co-producer melissa jacobson myself and
then they were stead constants and then
bringing different sound people over the
course of 11 years and we went up often
bill lives or lives two hours away from
where I'm based in New York City bill
lives a couple hours away so we were
there all the time and and then on the
road we would go join bill Bill's always
driving and we would head out on to meet
the people that bill wanted to meet so
we shot 300 hours and over the course of
as I said 11 years and then leads would
materialize people that we thought we
couldn't find he couldn't find that he
needed and desired to find he was able
to locate and off we went and then you
know certain things people deliberated
as to whether they really wanted to talk
to him
and over time he would communicate or we
would communicate and they would agree
and then off we went
how did you deal with the change in
technology over that 11 years because I
dslr's hadn't even come out yet audio
gear it's probably that's right so we
shot standard def at the beginning we
started shooting in two thousand four or
five six that standard F and then we're
shooting high def towards the end so you
just the film really for the most part
plays out chronologically so it it sort
of follows the technology in a way and
Tim we were able to up res some of the
standard F footage so that it's just
higher quality and it holds up and I
give enormous amount of credit to Trish
Pavoni she did a beautiful job shooting
the film it's a very very intimate film
the story is a very personal story and
were very the viewer is very closely
connected to Bill and so you know the
the footage that we shot and also we
took there's a lot of kind of remarkable
archival footage from the early four
1950s of Kitty that has never been seen
and archival footage also of the crime
scene that had never been even developed
so all of that sort of sort of
seamlessly interwoven by our two
wonderful editors Gabriel Rhodes and
Russell Greene you touched on briefly
that a lot of the people interviewed
were not part of the selfie generation
something that Mike Wallace said was so
fascinating this was I'm not sure if in
this 1960s but has apathy become a way
of life you think about now crimes
committed here even in LA or or people
fighting first thing people do is pull
out a cell phone and film it how do you
feel now with this technology where
we're all mini documentarians how has
this become a way of life how do we
remove ourselves from something so
personal or would we get involved do you
think you know it's interesting you you
asked that because the Mike Wallace is
speaking in a sense to a story that has
such deep and flaws in it that kitty
Genovese sort of represented apathy in
1964 well well did it
I mean sure they're people who didn't
act who saw and knew what was going on
but then there's this woman Sophia
Farrar who you know the the story of
indifference and no one helping has this
hero Sophia Farrar and so she runs out
and she cradles kitty in her arms so
kitty actually died in the arms of her
friend and so I I kind of I struggle
with this question of you know did that
represent apathy does present day with
cameras and people not acting represent
apathy I think I become more I'm more
skeptical of of stories representing
some label that that we all act in a
monolithic way
on any given day where a hero or a
coward this notion that somehow a story
becomes a morality play that that I
think is the fundamental problem with
the story of kitty Genovese is it it was
historic too good to check that it it
served as a totem a kind of
representation of who and what defining
of who and what we we were are when in
fact it's we're much more of all stripes
and what happened that night isn't 38
watched as if in an amphitheater but
some heard some didn't some acted some
didn't and so I tend to resist
personally labeling a story or a
narrative that takes place now and
saying it defines who we are and what we
are certainly there are moments when our
better selves do not come out and
invariably there is someone there's
often one who does stand up in hell
there was a Sophia Farrar that night and
for whatever reason the choice was made
to drop her from the narrative and tell
the story of thirty eight who didn't do
anything when in fact there was one at
least one who did do something so I'm
more skeptical when I hear or a story
that seems to define who we are
James what's the most important part of
the screenwriting process for you I'm
sure it varies from narrative filmmaking
to documentary filmmaking
dealing with the anxiety just being
patient and not questioning or I mean ah
it may be sound like a glib answer there
for me is the work I tend to do is a
very research-based and often requires
extensive other interviews or
documentation that finding documents
depends because I tend to do fact-based
work but then there's a moment when you
should gathered all this information and
you've got to remind yourself that the
people that you're writing about our
humans they're real people they're not
marble statues or photographs they're
their daughters and sisters mothers sons
and that process of sort of being
patient and and not rushing and racing
something I learned in this documentary
actually I couldn't possibly write seems
like some of the scenes that occur in
real life in the film I'm not nearly as
imaginative her creative it's just no
way scene that takes place between
Steven Moseley and bill Genovese or when
Michael Farrar is remembering what it
was like in the vestibule when he the
first time he stepped inside that
vestibule working after Kitty had been
murdered
well when bill meets with Kitty's lover
Mary Ann we're the guys in the bar I
can't write that well I don't have that
kind of imagination and so if I learned
anything from this process it's to be a
better listener take my time be more
patient you know real life has it's a
much much more creative writer than well
certainly than I am and I think that
that has been that's the deepest most
profound impact I think on my career as
a screenwriter just to be a better
listener take my time be more patient
more open